this quiet rural area in eastern
afghanistan was this morning met by
sheer destruction
a powerful earthquake rocking the
mountainous region of paktika has
crippled homes livelihoods and killed
hundreds
the death toll will continue to rise as
locals scrape through the rubble of
homes made from mud and bricks they can
only hope they find some signs of life
with many international aid agencies
fleeing the country after the taliban
takeover last year a response was slow
this was a major incident the country
wasn't prepared for there's no
sophisticated equipment up in these
villages
these are people who lived hand-to-mouth
you know the backdrop here in
afghanistan is that we're suffering the
worst drought for 37 years is a
malnutrition crisis there's the spread
of preventable diseases such as acute
watery diarrhea and measles so these
communities
are weakened by months and years of
challenges and so this has come at
exactly the wrong time
the de facto government sent helicopters
to help lift the injured to safety but
on the ground in these hard to reach
areas without a major international aid
presence treating people is proving
difficult
they'll be taken to the regional
hospitals but already we're hearing that
those hospitals are inundated there's
patients on the floor
so they will be taken
further afield
the mobile health nutrition teams will
be setting up
more tents
for triage
to treat those who are injured as well
neighboring pakistan and iran have said
they're prepared to help the afghan
authorities with any support they need
but with lots of rain over the last 48
hours and forecast for more the worry of
landslides and flooding is now prominent
and so
when such a big incident happens in any
country there is a need for help from
other countries
it is very difficult for us to be able
to respond to this huge incident
we asked the international community to
cooperate with us and continue their
support
this is afghanistan's deadliest natural
disaster for more than 20 years and with
a backdrop of drought a hunger crisis
and abandonment from the international
community
its effects are catastrophic intamin
rasheed sky news pakistan